- [Scott] ... everybody.
Welcome to this afternoon session,
this is AIM414, "How to
Optimize your LLM with NKI".
My name's Scott Perry,
I'm a solutions architect
on the Annapurna Labs team at AWS,
where we work directly with customers
on our AI/ML Accelerators
training Inferentia.
And joining me today, I have my colleague.
- [Sadaf] Hey everyone, this is Sadaf.
I'm also a solutions
architect at AWS Trainium.
I'm primarily focused on
AI/ML performance on Neuron,
and we both are super excited
to have you here today for this session.
- [Scott] Yeah, thanks for coming out.
So this is a code talk,
so we're gonna spend
most of the session digging into
a terminal editor and code editor,
running some scripts and
doing all of this live,
so hopefully it goes well.
But before we do that, we
do have to just go through
a few background slides, just
to give everybody an idea
of what neuron and NKI's all about.
So bear with us for a few slides,
and then we'll get right into it.
So to give you some context,
you know, for many years
customers have been doing
machine learning workloads on AWS,
and some of the early feedback
that we got from customers
is that they wanted some choice,
and they wanted to see
improved price performance
for running their ML workloads on AWS.
So back in about 2019,
we actually invested
in designing a purpose-built
machine learning accelerator
that we would offer via
EC2 instances in AWS.
And that first generation
was called AWS Inferentia.
So this is Inferentia one,
if you're used to the EC2 instances.
And this was a smaller accelerator
designed for the deep
learning models of the time.
This was kind of like Bert and
YOLO, and that sort of thing.
Since then, we've actually released
the second generation, Inferentia2,
and maybe more interestingly
we've also released three versions
of the AWS Trainium chip,
with the third generation
launching just yesterday.
So AWS Trainium is actually
a more powerful chip
capable of being used
for distributed training
as well as inference.
So at the heart of the Trainium
and Inferentia accelerator
chips are the neuron cores.
So in a given instance you
might have multiple chips,
and within each chip you can actually have
multiple neuron cores.
So today we're gonna be
working with a Trn2 instance.
It actually has eight physical
cores within the chip,
we're gonna be using one of them
for the examples here today.
But within that core, this
is a high-level schematic
of what's actually involved.
So what's really interesting
about this architecture is,
as I mentioned, it's purpose-built
for machine learning workloads.
So if you see, we have four
specific compute engines
within the neuron core.
Starting with the tensor engine,
this is focused on things like
matrix multiplications and transposes.
We have the vector engine that you can use
for max pool, average pool-type layers.
There's the scaler engine
for things like activations.
And we also have a
general-purpose compute engine
with general-purpose cores,
that can be reprogrammed for maybe layers
that aren't covered in
the other three engines.
So here we have four compute engines
that you can actually use
in parallel on this chip
to maximize compute utilization.
Also worth noting here is we
have a couple on-chip SRAMs,
you see the SBUF and the PSUM.
So these are obviously on-chip,
so they're very close to the compute,
offering high bandwidth
but maybe lower capacity.
We have a DMA, or a set of
DMA engines for moving data,
and we also have high-bandwidth memory
as part of the device.
And because these are offered via EC2
we also have access to the host memory,
in this case it would be
DRAM associated with the CPU.
So I'll call it, you
know, there's three levels
of the memory hierarchy
that we care about, right.
There's that on-chip SRAM,
this is the lower capacity
but very high-bandwidth memory
that we would love all
of our data to live on
all the time if it could.
We also, at the bottom of the
tiers, have the host memory,
which is high capacity
but lower bandwidth.
And in between we have, you
know, a bit of a compromise,
which is the HBM, moderate capacity
and pretty good bandwidth.
And one of the major struggles
when you're trying to optimize
your machine learning workloads is,
you know, how do you place data,
get it as close to the compute
exactly when you need it,
and how do you juggle moving
between the tiers otherwise?
(Scott sniffing)
And when we talk about optimizing
machine learning workloads,
one way of kind of
representing a given workload
is the roof line model.
Has anybody seen roof line model before?
(attendee speaking faintly)
Okay, just take a quick refresher then.
So as part of the roof line model,
basically for any given algorithm,
any given machine learning, say, model,
there's gonna be an arithmetic intensity
intrinsic to that model,
like an algorithmic arithmetic intensity.
So, basically, whatever the
mathematical operations are
for that given model, it's gonna consume
and there's gonna be a
certain amount of operations
that you have to do per
byte of memory that's read.
But for a given accelerator chip,
you're gonna have a
finite memory bandwidth
and you're gonna have a finite,
you know, maximum compute
throughput that you can achieve.
And if it turns out that your
achieved arithmetic intensity
for a given workload falls
on the left-hand side,
meaning that there's low ops per byte,
you're gonna be memory bound.
And we don't really want to be there,
'cause if we're in that case,
it means that we're limited by
how fast we can read from memory
for the workload that
we're actually operating.
What we would like to
do is try to push things
to the right-hand side of the
graph and be compute bound,
meaning that we're doing multiple,
many, many ops per byte of memory read,
so we can take full advantage
of the compute accelerators.
So the difference between algorithmic,
kind of theoretical arithmetic intensity
and achieved is basically,
you know, the implementation, right.
So how can we improve performance
and kind of shift the graph to the right?
So we can do things like
pipelining operations.
So if you have a major workload,
sometimes you can chunk
it up into smaller bits
and actually run multiple
parts of the workload
at any given time and keep
the engines a little busier
than they would be otherwise.
There's things like
minimizing data movement.
So if you're doing a lot of DMAs,
moving a lot of data
unnecessarily at the wrong time,
that's also gonna reduce your performance,
so we wanna try to avoid that.
We wanna maximize data throughput.
So in some cases you might
be sending small messages
or moving small bits of data around,
is there some way maybe
we can coalesce that
into larger chunks and
improve data throughput?
And if we're in a
distributed setting, sorry,
we might have multiple train chips
that we need to communicate
across sometimes,
so say synchronize
gradients during training.
And when that happens, it would be nice
if we could overlap the collectives
with some type of
compute or data movement,
so we're not just sitting there
waiting for the collectives to take place.
Okay, so, you know, this is why we,
and maybe how we would
try to improve performance
but what does it mean
for Trainium and Neuron?
How do we get there?
So to work with the Trainium
and the Inferentia chips,
we have the neuron SDK,
and this is the software development kit
that includes all of the
various layers of the stack.
So we have a compiler, runtime, driver,
and user tools that allow customers
to work with Trainium and Inferentia.
And, you know, we typically look at
our customers as three personas.
We have ML developers, data scientists,
and performance engineers,
and lots of folks kind of
fall between the lines,
but for today we're focused more
on the performance engineer persona.
And within the Neuron SDK
we have a certain set of tools
that are gonna be applicable
to performance engineers.
So the one that we want
to focus the most on today
is called the Neuron
Kernel Interface, NKI.
Has anybody worked with NKI
before or heard about it?
Okay, awesome.
So what is NKI?
So NKI is essentially a Python-based
domain-specific language
for writing kernels
for Trainium and Inferentia.
So before we had NKI,
basically you could write your
machine learning model
maybe in PyTorch and JAX,
run it through the neuron compiler,
which takes the compute
graphs from your model,
optimizes them to run on
Trainium or Inferentia,
and then you could run
your model that way.
But you're putting a lot of faith
in that the general-purpose
kind of neuron compiler
was gonna perfectly optimize your model.
And as we see with our accelerators
and other accelerators,
oftentimes customers need
a lower-level access.
They want to be able to
really fine-tune the model
to take full advantage of
the underlying hardware,
and that's what NKI offers you.
So if you're familiar with OpenAI Triton,
this is not quite Triton,
this is a little bit different
but this is our kind of flavor
of writing low-level kernels
for our accelerators.
So it integrates directly
with PyTorch, JAX, and NumPy.
It directly emits Neuron ISA instructions,
so the actual hardware instructions
that exist on the chips
get emitted from this platform.
And we have a couple
namespaces within NKI.
We have the NKI Lang,
which is higher-level
constructs to help you out,
helper functions, that kind of thing.
But we also have direct
Neuron ISA instructions
as part of the NKI ISA namespace.
And on the left-hand
side you do see a kernel.
We're gonna actually hop
into that in a minute here
and go through it line by line,
and show you what it's like
to build a basic kernel
before we get into the actual
benchmarking and whatnot.
Okay, so for today's session,
what are we looking to
achieve here in record time?
We're gonna start off, we want to start by
benchmarking and profiling an LOM.
In this case it's gonna be Qwen3.
So we're gonna run that using
Hugging Face Transformers
and the Neuron SDK, so it's gonna compile
the basic Qwen implementation
to run on Trainium as is,
using naive attention.
That's just gonna be our baseline.
So we'll look at the performance
and look at a basic profile.
Then Sadaf's gonna walk us through
an actual NKI kernel
implementation of attention.
He's gonna add that into the Qwen3 model
that we had previously run,
and we're gonna redo the
benchmarking and the profiling
to see what the performance
gains hopefully are
at the end of the session.
And then we'll obviously
give you guys some time
for questions at the end.
(Scott sniffing)
And the technology stack
we're using specifically here today,
so we're using AWS Trainium2,
the second generation of our chip.
On a smaller instance,
we're gonna be using
one of the neuron cores out of eight
that exist on the chip today,
just to kind of keep things
a little bit more consumable.
We're gonna be using the Neuron STK
to both compile and run our models.
In our case, today we're using Qwen3-0.6B,
an embedding model.
And this is available via the
Hugging Face Transformers library.
Okay, so with that, why don't
we just take a quick look
at that example kernel
that I put on the slide
in a code editor, we'll go through it,
and then we'll get right
into the benchmarking
and show you that vanilla implementation.
Okay. Awesome.
Okay, so here we can
see a very basic kernel,
in this case it's called
nki_tensor_add_kernel.
This is just a basic kernel that takes two
similarly shaped tensors,
and it does element-wise addition of them.
The first thing I want you to notice here
is this is just defined as a
basic Python function, right,
so the only thing that's really
special about this function
is that we decorate it with nki.jit,
just to let the neuron compiler know
that this is basically intended to be
a NKI kernel that we want to compile.
And there's a specific constraint
around the NKI kernels today.
So the inputs and the outputs,
you can see the A input, B input,
these are the two tensors
that will be added
as well as the output.
These need to exist on HBM, right,
so we talked about the three
kind of tiers of memory
that we're gonna be focused on.
The input and outputs
actually have to exist
on the on-device memory but
not on the on-chip SRAM.
And the framework is
gonna handle that for us,
so we'll be using PyTorch today.
So if we just run through
kind of line by line
what this is doing, we pass in two inputs
that we want to add together.
There's a basic check to make
sure they're the same shape,
otherwise the element
wise edition won't work.
And here we're gonna see
there's a similar flow
that exists in all NKI Kernels,
so the first step is we need to allocate
some space on the on-chip SRAMs.
So here we're allocating some space
for both the A input tensor
and the B input tensor,
using this sbuf.view.
And SBUF is one of our on-chip SRAMs.
And the next step is we
actually use an ISA instruction.
This is a DMA copy where we specify
that we want a copy from the A
input and B input HBM tensors
to the on-chip tensors, okay.
And, similarly, we actually
do something similar,
we allocate some space for the result.
In this case we call it c_tile.
And, again, this is on SBUF,
we use sbuf.view to allocate
the space for the tensor,
and then we use the ISA
tensor_tensor instruction
to actually do the addition for us.
So here you can specify
that this tensor_tensor op
is using the addition operator.
The two inputs are the two tiles
that we had basically passed
in and copied to SRAM,
and then we're opening the
results to the destination,
which is the c_tile.
And then, lastly, because we
need to get the outputs back
to HBM to return back to the framework,
we use HBM view to allocate
an HBM-hosted tensor,
and then again we use a DMA copy
to get the results back to HBM
before we return the result.
So, again, this is a
bit of a trivial kernel
just to kind of give
you the high-level flow,
but you can see that this is,
you know, fairly low level
if you've been used to working
with PyTorch and whatnot.
But, you know, if you're
really looking to squeeze
the best bang for buck out of your model
and make the best use of the hardware,
there's gonna be cases
where you might need to
actually get this deep into the space.
Okay, with that, let's take a quick look
at the benchmarking script here.
So I didn't want to just
blindly run a script,
so I am gonna run through the code
a little bit with you here,
just to show you what we're running.
But this is just a basic Python script,
it uses Hugging Face
Transformers and the Qwen3 model,
and essentially we load the
Qwen3 model on CPU first,
we're gonna compile it for neuron
and then we're gonna run
a bunch of inferences
and kind of time latency,
and measure the throughput that way.
And we'll also do a
sanity check against CPU
to make sure that the model
results are the same as CPU.
Okay, so if we skip over the imports,
there's a little bit of environment setup
that we use for neuron for the runtime.
In this case, we want to specify
that we're just using a
single core, for example.
We're also, because we're going
to be doing some profiling,
we enable some profiling,
enabling environment variables here
just to make sure that we
capture the metrics that we need.
Okay, so we do wrap the
model in a basic class here.
This is just to make
it a little bit easier
to get the last hidden state
from this embedding model,
just to kind of make things
a little bit easier for the demo today.
But the class, you can see,
it doesn't really do anything
other than do a forward pass
with the outputting only
the last hidden state.
We also have a helper function
that encodes some example text
and returns a repeating tensor
based on the batch size that we specify.
So it's just gonna be the same text
kind of repeated over and over
based on the batch size that
we need, just to help us out.
And we have a few arguments that we use
to control the behavior
of the benchmark script.
Obviously, like controlling things like
batch size and max length,
it's nice to be able to tweak that
as you're doing the executions.
But we also have a NKI flag here
that we use to specify
whether or not the benchmarking script
should use the NKI implementation
that Sadaf is gonna add
for us a little bit later.
Okay, so here you can see this is where
we actually load the model
for the first time onto CPU.
We do truncate the model
to four layers here,
just to speed things up
and get this done in
45 minutes here today.
But essentially the performance for,
you know, a handful of layers
should be similar to the
performance for the full model,
you just have to scale it up accordingly.
Okay, and if we skip
down a little bit here...
So this is where we actually
get into the meat of it.
So if we've previously run the script
for this configuration,
we're gonna cache the Neuron
compiled model on disk
just to save time in case
we wanna run it again.
But if it isn't compiled, we use this
torch_neuronx.trace call.
And this is what actually triggers
the neuron compiler to take the code.
In this case it's just
the vanilla implementation
of Qwen3 with naive attention.
It's gonna pass that
into the Neuron compiler,
the Neuron compiler
will extract the graphs,
compile them to run on Neuron
using the example inputs
that we've provided,
and it returns a PyTorch loadable model
that we can then save to disk,
and we cache it out to disk.
Okay, so if we haven't
compiled it we compile it,
and if it's already on
disk we just load it in.
We do a quick warmup inference,
we run through an iteration
of five inferences
measuring the inference time,
and then we calculate the
accuracy compared to CPU
and output the results.
Okay, so it should be
pretty straightforward
if you've worked with Hugging Face before.
But, again, I just wanted
to show you the code
so it wasn't a mystery.
And why don't we actually run this
and get into the heart of it here?
Okay, so if you open up the terminal here,
I'm logged into a TRN2 three XL instance,
and we have a Neuron SDK environment
already available to us, right,
so we can run commands like
neuron-ls, for example,
to get a quick breakdown
of what's available
on this instance type.
But let's just run the
benchmarking script here, Python...
(keyboard keys clacking)
Okay, and what we should see is
that it detects that
the previous CPU outputs
are saved on disk to save
time, and it loads those,
and it also loads the
pre-compiled Neuron model for us.
Again, just to save a couple minutes.
And within a few seconds
we should start to see this
executing the model on the Neuron core.
So, again, this is Qwen3-0.6B,
it's a four-layer version of that model
using a 16K sequence length.
Okay, and it's just about done running,
and now we get the accuracy,
just to prove it to you.
So the MSE Loss and the cosine similarity
are what we would expect.
So the outputs of this
neuron compiled model
that didn't run on CPU, it
actually ran on the accelerator,
they 100% match the CPU
outputs, which is great.
But on the performance side,
you can see that this is not
a very performant model
out of the box, right?
We're only getting .35 prompts a second
with latency around three seconds.
So I think there's definitely
room for improvement there,
and one of the areas where we often look
to improve performance
for transformer models
is the attention block.
So we'll take a look at that shortly.
But before we do that,
I did want to show you
that we can actually look
at the profiling results
that we captured here as well.
So sometimes what you'll see is that,
you know, maybe you're actually
getting great device time,
the model's actually
running well on Trainium
but there's something else
going on at the PyTorch layer
that's slowing things down.
So if we get a system level
view, a system profile here,
we'll be able to see did
this model actually run
kind of best we could expect for right now
before we add NKI.
So as part of the Neuron STK
we do have Neuron Profile,
which is the profiling tool.
There's different interfaces for this.
Today we're just gonna output
the system level profile
in a Perfetto compatible format
so that we can quickly
load it up in Perfetto,
which is an open-source visualization tool
that you're probably familiar with.
So we'll do neuron-profile view,
we specify the directory that
contains the profiling data,
and we'll tell it to use
--output-format perfetto.
(keyboard keys clacking)
Okay. And now if we look in the directory,
it's created the system profile for us
so we'll just quickly download that.
And let's hop into the
browser and this is Perfetto,
has anybody used proto
before for any kind of-
Okay, awesome. So you're familiar.
Yeah, so we'll just open up the trace file
and we'll take a quick look here.
Awesome. So if you're not familiar,
this is just showing
the execution timeline,
starting on the left, kind
of scrolling to the right.
You can see the first thing
that happened, there's NRT load.
This is actually the neuron runtime
loading the weights of the model into HBM.
And then beyond that you see
all these NRT execute calls,
and what's nice is we can actually see
exactly what's happening
within the neuron runtime.
So here it's executing the model,
you can see there's
basically seven executions
in the model here.
So our benchmarking loop was five,
but we also did one execution
for the accuracy check
and one is a quick warmup,
so that's why there's seven.
But if we click on any
of these executions,
you can actually see some metadata
associated with the execution,
which for this model may
be not that interesting
but for a larger model
or maybe an execution
where you had multiple graphs
executing on different cores,
this would be very helpful.
So here we can see the
exact name of the graph,
which is the compiled version
of the model for Neuron,
and we can see, you know, which
Neuron Core it's running on,
those sorts of things.
And on the left-hand side, you can see,
you know, the duration of the execution
is pretty much what we saw
from our benchmarking script.
It's just under three
seconds execution latency,
which is, you know, I'd say not great.
So hopefully we can improve on that.
But, yeah, with that being said,
this is the baseline performance.
So we did take that original
Qwen3 model from Hugging Face,
we compiled it to run on their own,
we executed it on train and
got those baseline results.
And now let's see if Sadaf can
improve on that, using NKI.
- [Sadaf] Sure. Thanks, Scott.
Thanks for setting up the stage.
Hey everyone, this is Sadaf again.
How many of you have lunch already?
Oh man, so sorry.
Not a good time to talk about
the code after lunch, (laughs)
but I promise you we will try to make it
as exciting and promising as possible.
Just bear with us.
What we are trying to
do here essentially is,
as we have seen performance
for this Qwen3 model,
we got the performance numbers
and we got the timeline as well,
and we'll try to see if NKI,
which is Neuron Kernel
Interface, as Scott mentioned,
can help us to improve this performance.
So in this part of the talk,
we are going to focus on
three major objectives.
Number one, I would like to show you
how quick and convenient it is
to integrate NKI kernels
in our existing model code.
Number two, what are the
performance impacts of the same?
And number three, which is going to be
more like food for thought,
like from the extensibility
and applications point of view,
is there a way we can
use those NKI kernels
in our respective workloads
when we go back home?
So these are the three major objectives
that we are going to address
in this part of the talk.
Are you with me? We are going to do
a little bit of code, as I promised,
I'll try not to make
it very boring for you
but we'll do our best.
We good? Awesome.
All right, so there are a couple of things
that I think are worth noting from
the profiling that we have done so far.
We see, like for each iteration,
it's taking approximately two
seconds, 812 milliseconds.
On a rough basis we can
just say it's three seconds.
Are you able to hear me there?
Awesome. That is one.
Second, as Scott was trying to show,
the throughput that we are seeing here
is 0.35 prompts per second.
So technically it means
that it takes approximately
three seconds to just process one prompt.
We good?
So when we are talking about
NKI, and as Scott mentioned,
like how does it help us
to improve the performance?
And the reason it can do that,
because it works at the very low level,
which is very close to the hardware,
and it takes care of all the optimizations
that are available on the table
so that we can get the maximum performance
from the underlying hardware,
which is Trainium in this case.
So we are very proud and excited about
that yesterday we
launched the NKI Library,
which Scott is going to
talk about in a minute,
and we are exposing some of the kernels,
predefined, pre-implemented kernels,
which can be plugged into your models
just like we are going to
say in this Qwen3 model,
and we can just take advantage
of the performance on Trainium.
So let's have a look at that.
People who have worked with
Hugging Face Transformers Library before,
we would know for each model directory
we have different model-specific files.
So in the case of Qwen3 we
have a configuration file here,
we have a modeling file,
modular file, and so on.
The very first file that I'm
super interested in right now
is this modeling file.
Let me try to make this
screen a little bit better.
Sorry, there's a question.
(attendee speaking faintly)
We'll talk about that, yes.
So the reason I'm interested
in this modeling Qwen3 file,
because this file, essentially,
which is given by Hugging
Face Transformers Library,
tells us the complete implementation
of Qwen3 model, right.
If I want to understand
what the RMS norm looks
like for Qwen3, it is here.
If I want to understand what
MLP looks like for Qwen3,
it is here.
And how the rotary embedding looks like
or how it is implemented,
everything is here.
And one part that we are
super interested today
is attention.
Everybody heard about
transformer-based models?
Everybody heard about attention, right?
So that's what we are going to see today.
We have this eager
attention forward method
that has been provided by
the Hugging Face Transformers
Library itself for this model,
and what we are going to do is
we are trying to see if there's a way
we can replace this with
NKI attention, right?
And we will see what is the
performance implication of the same.
So that is one module
that we are going to be
super interested in today.
What I'm going to do is, let me first...
I'm going to take this attention,
eager attention forward here,
and I'm just going to paste it.
Everybody can see the code,
do I need to maximize it?
Are we good?
Awesome. So I just copy-pasted
that eager_attention,
and let's give it a meaningful name.
Let's call it, like,
nki_attention_forward, right.
And I'll not touch the input arguments
but I'm going to, of course,
get rid of this implementation
because we are going to write
our own implementation here.
And we'll return the attention output,
and because it's inference
we don't need to return
the beats, so we're good.
Step number one of my
objective is to showcase
how easy and convenient it
is to integrate NKI Kernels
in our existing models.
That's what we are going
to look at right now.
So we have this attention
forward.py file here,
and we can go into the detail in a minute,
but what it has is it
has the implementation,
the NKI implementation
for different flavors of attention, right.
So as we know, we have SDP attention,
we have sliding window attention,
we have flash attention,
and so many other variations of that.
It has the implementation
for the majority of those
profound implement attention mechanisms,
and we are going to use one of them.
In this case, we are going to leverage
flash attention for Qwen3.
So what this file does,
what this implementation file does, is
on top of that it provides
me kind of an adapter,
or you can just think of
like an interface function.
And what it does is it will
take all the inputs from me,
it will try to make sure basic hygiene,
like I'm giving the right
shapes, formats, data types,
and then it'll invoke
the right kernel for us.
We definitely are going to
look into that kernel as well,
but before that let's invoke this kernel
from our modeling_qwen3.py.
All right, so my attention
output will be coming from here
and I'm going to call this one.
But as we were looking at it,
and we can go through this
provided documentation as well,
because it's a NKI
implementation of the kernel
it expects us to provide the QKV tensors
in a specific format or
specific shapes, right,
because very close to the hardware
it expects us to do that little bit of,
you know, massaging, reshaping before,
and then give those tens back to NKI
so that it can perform its operations.
So for that we need to make
a little bit of reshaping
for our QKV tensors right now.
So for query, the first
thing I'm going to do is,
we know if I expose the shape of my query,
or key or value in this case,
I will get the batch size,
number of heads, sequence
length, and head dimension.
That's what it's going to give to me.
This kernel, the attention
kernel, it expects the query.
I'm going to write it as a comment here
so that we keep track of it.
So it says, "Okay, you are
in this format right now,
but I expect you to give me
the query in this format."
Just a little bit of reshaping, permute,
and all these classical NumPy operations
that we are going to perform here.
Okay, so what we are going to do is
from b, h, s, d, to bXh, d, s,
essentially we are
contracting two dimensions
to one dimension and then
changing the sequence
of SD and DS. That's it.
So what we can do is, first
of all, we do a permute
to switch S and D, or
swap the sequence length
and the head dimension.
So we will make it first b, h, d, s,
and then I think it'll be easy from there
to make it bXh d, s.
So let's do that.
So query = query.clone.permute.
And the reason we are doing it,
because we need to change
the sequence of the shapes,
b, h, s, d to b, h, d, s.
So zero will remain zero,
one will remain one,
two will become three,
and three will become two.
So far good.
So we have achieved b, h, d, s,
and then we will reshape it to bXh, d, s.
As simple as that, and
we will ask to give us
contiguous memory location
so that's optimized.
Fair enough.
We just reshaped our
query tensors, that's it.
Now, similarly, we can do the
same for key tensors as well.
So our key is exactly in the same shapes,
so we just need to make the
change to my tensor names here,
key states, and everything
remains the same.
For values, it's even simpler.
For values, it says give me bXh, s, d.
So we don't need to do the permute here,
we can simply just reshape.
And then, since we don't have to permute
we can keep the s and d at
their original positions.
Fair enough.
And once we have this, it means I'm ready
to provide these tensors
to this adapter kernel,
and I'm going to call this
so we can provide our query,
key states, value
states, and then scaling.
(keyboard keys clacking)
Yeah. And yeah, just
change the variable names.
Thank you.
So that it's not key,
it's values. Fair enough.
So what we have done so far,
we have changed our QKV shapes.
That's it, did not make any
changes to the tensor values,
did not make any other changes,
just reshaped them in the
format that this kernel expects.
Once we do that, we would be able
to call this attention through NKI,
passing out our parameters,
and we'll get the attention output.
Once we get the attention output,
the beauty of it that's going to give us
attention output in this format,
and we would like to have
it in the final outcome
should be in this format, b, s, h, d.
So we need to do the exactly
same magic here as well.
So first of all, we
are going to reshape it
so that it becomes b, h, s, d.
(keyboard keys clacking)
And then we just need
to swap s and h, right.
So right now we have h, s,
then we're gonna make it s, h.
So we'll just call our favorite function,
which is transfers,
and then we will transpose the first index
with the second index, contiguous.
All right. Awesome.
And then we return the attention output.
If we look at the implementation of this,
we have just swapped query key values-
not swapped, reshaped.
And once we have reshaped them
we have called the attention
kernel, getting the output,
again, reshaping it in the expected format
that the function output
requires, and then using it.
Another thing that we have
to do is we have to switch,
because there is a place
where we are calling the attention here.
What I have done here is
I have already added this,
like if my config has the NKI
as an attention implementation,
call NKI attention forward.
So we are switching from eager
attention to NKI attention,
so that we are 100% sure
that we are calling the right attention.
Fair enough. So let's quickly have a look,
I'm going to remove the previous profiles.
As we have seen when Scott was running,
he was able to get the profiles.
I'm going to delete it
so that we don't have any
cache data or something.
And then we will try
to make it run as well,
so let's have our terminal open.
(attendee coughing)
And this time I'm going
to call the same script
which Scott has run,
but this time I'm going to
pass this argument, right.
So hope it runs first time.
Let's do it.
What is going to happen now
is because it has found a new attention,
it's going to submit the model again
for the neuron compiler.
Hey, I got this new attention,
just compile it for me so that
I can run on Trainium, right.
So this compilation will take
maybe a couple of minutes.
Meanwhile, it's taking
a couple of minutes,
let's have a quick look at
the actual attention kernel
that I promised to you.
So I'm, again, going to
the attention forward py,
and here if we look at our adapter kernel
I will save all these details for you,
you can check it out later,
but what essentially I can see,
it's calling this attention kernel
implementation without swapping.
I am more interested to find out
where's the definition of this kernel.
So here it is, line number 657.
And, just to warn you, it's a
pretty decent implementation,
it's like 1,000 lines of code.
So I don't want to bore you with that,
but what I want to share with you is that
because, at the end of the day,
attention is nothing but
a function of QKVs essentially, right.
We are doing QK transpose, softmax,
and then multiplying this with V, right.
So this is exactly what it is doing,
but it is doing it in a
very hardware aware fashion.
What it means, it means with NKI
we have this amazing capabilities
that we can take the maximum advantage
of the underlying hardware,
which is Trainium.
So what it does is it
employs various memory
as well as compute
optimization techniques.
And when I'm saying memory
optimization techniques,
it uses smart DMAs just to ensure
we are efficiently using the DMA engines,
we are efficiently using the
DMA package sizes as well.
It uses the intelligent tiling concepts,
it uses the efficient memory
layout and allocations.
When it comes to compute,
what it's going to do is
it takes advantage of pipelining
so that, you know, as Scott was mentioning
in one of the slides
where we have different compute engines,
it makes sure that it is trying to keep
all the compute engines
as much busy as possible in parallel,
so that we can- whatever
the available compute
that we have on the table, we
can take the best out of that.
It also uses the concept of op fusion,
like when we are fusing
or kind of combining
multiple operations together
so that we don't have to do a lot of DMEs,
a lot of memory accesses,
we can keep our compute
engines more and more busy.
So it employs all these mechanisms
to get the best performance from Trainium,
and once you employ all these mechanisms
what you get is a super optimized
implementation of your model,
or a specific module that you're
talking about that, right.
So after a couple of minutes
we see the compiler status is passed.
Now it's going to run the inference
with this new attention implementation.
Remember, it's not running
the naive attention anymore,
it is running the NKI attention this time.
Fair enough?
And this time the performance that we see
is 2.99 prompts per second.
Can anybody remind me
what was the performance
that we have seen with
the naive attention?
Exactly, 0.352, almost
three prompts per second.
So we are talking about like
approximately like six to
eight times better performance,
not six to 8%, six to eight
x performance boost here.
Isn't it amazing, right?
So let's have a look
at the profile as well.
So just like Scott has
generated the profile,
we are going to generate
the profile again.
We are going to download
this system profile,
and this time we are going to
save it with, let's say, NKI.
We go to Perfetto again.
Remember this time as well,
Scott was mentioning two
seconds, 812 milliseconds,
approximately three seconds, right.
Now, let's open this NKI trace this time,
which we have just got, and
let's expand it a little bit.
Hmm. And let's see the time.
Are we ready for that?
Now if we go there, the duration
from almost three seconds
to almost a quarter of a second.
Right. So the point I'm
trying to drive over here
is that with this performance,
with this NKI kernel we are getting almost
six to eight x performance
boost right in front of us.
And that was my second objective.
First was to showcase how easy it is
to integrate a NKI kernel.
That's what we have done.
And what is the performance implication
or performance boost
that we get out of it.
The third objective that
I was trying to drive is
a food for thought.
Think about it, it is just a small model
with just one attention module
or attention part of the model
that we have replaced with NKI.
Now this model has much more than that.
It has MLP also, which
is super compute bound.
It has QKV projections,
output projections and so on.
And Scott will drive us-
in a moment he'll help us to understand
like we have some of these kernels exposed
to the outside world, first time ever.
These are the production scale kernels
that we can use in our own models
and leverage this amazing
performance boost.
So, again, going back
to the performance gain.
From throughput, for the naive attention,
we got this one story building
to almost 10 story building now,
and from the latency's point of view,
which we want to be as small as possible,
we have come down from there to here.
(attendee speaking faintly)
Yeah, sorry. Please.
(attendee speaking indistinctly)
Do we have the profile of what?
- [Attendee] For power consumption?
- [Sadaf] I don't think we do profiling
based on the power
consumption as of today.
Yeah. So with that, I
leave the floor for Scott.
He'll drive us home from here.
- Thank you.
- Awesome. Thank you, Sadaf.
So, as you saw, guys,
we were able to go from
not so great performance
to pretty impressive performance gains,
basically just by adding
a few lines of code
and taking advantage of a kernel
that's been built essentially
by the Annapurna team.
What we're really excited
to talk about, though, is
just yesterday we launched NKI Library.
So this is an open source project,
it contains a number of
pre optimized NKI kernels
that are written by our team,
you know, curated, tested,
and maintained by our team
and provided on GitHub.
So starting off, there's a number of
kernels available there today.
You can grab the QR code and take a look.
So there's a lot of, you
know, dense model support
kind of in the beginning now,
we're gonna add additional models around-
or additional kernels
around mixture of experts
and other use cases and workloads as well.
But this is super exciting
because up until now,
you know, NKI's still in beta
but it gives customers this access
to the lower level compute engines
that you just didn't have before.
Right, so you saw the naive,
you know, implementation of
Qwen when we compiled it.
It did run, it gave accurate results,
but the performance was really
lackluster out of the box.
But with NKI, we were able to
drastically close the gap there
and really drive amazing
performance with this model.
And, again, like we
focused on attention today
but there's a lot of other
aspects of different models,
different layers that you
might be able to apply NKI to.
And it's a little bit
like onion peeling, right?
You're gonna get into a workload,
you'll do a device level profile,
figure out where the bottlenecks are,
maybe you tackle some of those with NKI,
it moves the bottleneck
somewhere else, right.
And at some point, you know,
you almost chase it forever,
but at least with NKI
it puts the capabilities
to the customer's hands
that you can actually do
this performance engineering
that just wasn't possible
from the PyTorch level before.
So awesome. With that,
I want to thank everybody
for coming out today.
Really appreciate you coming
in for an afternoon session
to learn about Trainium and NKI.
We have a number of other
Neuron and Trainium
sessions today and tomorrow,
if you're interested in checking them out.
And we're open for questions.
Thank you.
- All right, thanks folks.
(attendees applauding)